this video was sponsored by babble the
language learning app used by millions
more about them at the end of the video
since 1931 were at the end of the very
profitable Prohibition era in New York
and at the time things were pretty
lawless in the criminal underworld there
are all sorts of Italian gangs Irish
gangs Jewish gangs and it was complete
chaos
your Lucky Luciano an up-and-coming
mobster in New York's largest Italian
gang or Borgata headed by Giuseppe
Masseria also known as Jill the boss but
unlike your archaic traditionalist boss
you're a part of a rising second
generation of Italian mobsters I spoke
English and were raised in America he
was of Sicilian birth Sicilian on both
sides of his family and you needed that
in those days to make anywhere in the
Mafia but at the same time he was more
Americanized you didn't care for silly
things like only doing business when
Italians were defending your pride and
ego where your life you just wanted to
make some money and live the American
dream he didn't care what your
nationality was or what your religion
was if I can trust you and we can make
money we'll work together Lucky Luciano
what was his power what was his talent
what kind of a man who shared a relevant
warning you were a entrepreneur first in
a Sicilian second it wasn't that he was
more violent than the other guys wasn't
that he was more dangerous Luciano was
able to control his emotions and
preserve equanimity when things got hot
you saw the opportunity to make even
more money by spending the family's
operations into new ventures like labor
racketeering gambling and prostitution
but when you presented your ideas to Joe
the boss he dismissed them claiming that
we were already making enough money with
bootlegging and your animosity towards
him only grew Joe Abbas was in the
middle of raging the bloodiest mob war
at the time against the second-biggest
Italian or gotcha headed by Salvatore
Maranzano it's been going on for nearly
two years now and sources say he left
around 60 monsters dead in the streets
that's 60 perfectly good hard-working
people that could have been making us
money but now they're dead all because
your boss was too power-hungry and
caught up in this giant ego so needless
to say you've grown a little
disenchanted by all this violence
prohibition was making us Millions and
with so many other opportunities to make
money in this great city
huh skill
there was such a waste of time and
attracted the wrong attention and when
no end in sight if you don't do
something to stop this war law
enforcement will definitely crackdown on
us ruining business for everyone but
here's the problem
even if war were to end right now with
how unorganized all these gangs are at
war will almost certainly break out
again in the future
interfering with our bottom line we need
a way to organize this mess to avoid
future conflicts within families and
between families if we had some kind of
structure like this not only will we
have lasting peace in the mafia world
but we could all work together to most
efficiently plunder the richest city and
country in the world so after some
murders here in layered use
single-handedly and in this war and
created the Commission to do exactly
that a National Board of Directors or
supreme courts of sorts made up of the
biggest mafia families the Commission
decided who lives or dies and set the
rules and centers for everyone to follow
it settled disputes between families but
most importantly you managed to bring
together this group of complete
Psychopaths to work together
imperfect profitable lasting harmony an
organized crime was born skyrocketing
the Mafia into the greatest most
powerful criminal organization the US
has ever seen this is that story
Luciano promised something truly
revolutionary he was going to literally
organized-crime let me set anything at
all everybody listen Jim yeah yeah lucky
yeah yeah lucky left everybody left you
can apply the word genius to crime Lucky
Luciano was a genius this war that you
found herself in all started when her
boss Giuseppe Jill the boss Masseria got
the brilliant idea that he would be able
to declare himself the boss of bosses
and all the other gangs would just
submit to his rule big mistake
oh god sure one a boss when he started
the meeting payoffs as the boss of
bosses from salvatore maranzano the boss
of the second biggest italian Borgata
Maranzano refused so john Lavasa hitmen
start picking off Maranzano soldiers and
the Costello Maurice a war was born fast
forward eighteen months later to today
you finally decide that you had enough
of this war and this is how you end it
you went to Maranzano and made a deal
behind your boss's back I will kill
Jolla boss for you you'll get the claim
victory over this war and in exchange
you'll recognize me as your equal in a
new boss of Joe's family Maranzano
accepted so now it's time to do the hits
by now both bosses have been completely
on edge for the last 18 months making
them both very cautious and paranoid for
their lives simply drove around an
armored cars for 1 inch thick
bulletproof glass and have bodyguards
around them 24/7 so if you're gonna kill
your boss you need to find a way to
catch him off guard his bodyguards also
shared your frustration with the war so
getting them in on the scheme wasn't too
hard and on April 15 1931 you set up a
fancy lobster lunch meeting with Joe
Abbas at one of his favorite restaurants
under the ruse that was to brainstorm a
way to kill his rifle but you and I both
know that if the exact opposite you
arrived at the restaurant early to set
up the hit Joe the boss arrives on his
armored car with three bodyguards and
before dessert arrived you excuse
yourself to use the restroom Joe's body
was mysteriously vanished and four of
your him and enter and riddled that old
man with some good old-fashioned lead
when the police arrived you had the
convenient alibi that you were washing
your hands in the restroom and saw none
of it and boom the war was over
Maranzano was crowned the victor and
recognized us the boss along with giving
his blessing to three other big New York
Mafia families you were just relieved
that we could finally start moving
forward and make some progress but
getting promoted to the boss of the
biggest crime family was also a nice
touch too
but that hope was so short-lived when
Maranzano decided to go back on his deal
and make the same arrogant mistake that
Joe the boss did he summon all the major
mafia leaders around the country and
declared himself as the new boss of all
bosses what many demands to follow
Maranzano forced all the families until
its height chain of command that the
Mafia would later be known for with a
boss or Godfather at the top an
underboss below him to handle all the
family's operations with their
underlings at the bottom that did all
the dirty work which were organized in
the crews each crew consisting of a
captain or capo and indefinite soldiers
Maranzano also brought all the
traditional rules of the Sicilian Mafia
to America like ultimate stew servants
to the Godfather and their code of
silence of omertà seeing Maranzano
betray you like this was the moment
where you realized that you killed jewel
Abbas only for an even more power hungry
and backwards thinking oh man to replace
him and as if it couldn't get any worse
a friend of yours on the Maranzano
family found out that Maranzano marked
you for a machine gun assassination just
a mere five months after you handed him
the throne on a silver platter and if he
don't act fast you're gonna be lying
next to your old boss
now obviously the only choice you have
is to kill Maranzano is either you in a
body bag or him but just like Joe Lobos
you can bet that Maranzano is also armed
to the teeth 24/7 especially with all
the noise he's been making so we need to
find an opening conveniently you were
also tipped off that Maranzano was
experiencing some tax troubles in his
import-export business fronts he was
expecting some IRS agents to come and
audit his books so just to be safe he
ordered his bodyguards to be unarmed
while the IRS agents were snooping
around this is your opening so on
September 10 1931 five months after
killing Joe Lobos a group of non
Italians you hired showed up at merizan
o--'s office posing as IRS agents they
worked out their guns got the drop on
Maranzano's bodyguards lined everyone up
against the wall your insider friend Lou
Casey who would later become another
legendary mob boss pointed out whom
Arizona was one on the Hitman directed
him into his office and after hearing a
struggle in a stream of gunfire
Maranzano lay dead letting everyone know
what will happen if they double-cross
you
and within just five short months you
went from being entangled in an all-out
war to being at the very top in peace
now one might expect that you killing a
second boss would lead to another war
but for the most part you won the war of
public perception in the Mafia community
Maranzano was clearly plotting your
demise so people easily accepted your
self-defense claim even Maranzano
sportage a mafioso Joe Bonanno thought
his boss wasn't with the times and but
now don't believe that.you killing his
boss was the path to peace your first
hero that's right with salvatore
maranzano
yeah and you letting him take over his
bosses position was also a nice perk Joe
Bonanno would also later go down in
history as another legendary boss and on
top of that everyone was wondering who
you were gonna off next which didn't
inspire a much retaliation now you
finally have the power and influence to
cement the lasting peace you so
desperately been craving so you and
Bonanno meet with three other big Mafia
families in New York and create a pact a
cartel where each family will get their
own dedicated cities to rule over and to
make sure that they crush all the other
existing New York crime families at the
time so they wouldn't have to put up
with any pesky competition these five
crime families will later grow to
dominate and completely control New York
and will later be known as simply the
five families today each of the five
families are referred to by their most
famous ruling Godfather Bonanno Colombo
Gambino Genovese and Lucchese but you
have bigger plans than just keeping the
peace in New York you know that if any
other Wars broke out in the future in
New York or elsewhere the five families
will be thrown into the same bucket by
law enforcement in the public so with
the five families secured you set up a
national conference where Al Capone is
Chicago with over 20 other Mafia
families around the country and this is
where the magic happens you led the
group to submit an assistant that made
sure everyone got their fair share of
the profits all the families avoided
wars with then in between different
families and to make sure that every
family was structured for maximum
efficiency first a lot of the ideas
Maranzano force on everyone were pretty
backwards and irrelevance but some of
the war practicals like the strict
structure of families with a boss
underboss and crews to insulate upper
management from getting prosecuted from
the day-to-day crimes of blows at the
bottom and omerta their code of silence
so you kept the good ideas
throughout the bad ones without letting
your pride and emotions get in the way
one innovation was to add another world
to the family structure the console area
this was the family's expert advisor
that acted as yet another defense
mechanism to help settle disputes in and
between families before things got
bloody although you didn't care the
people you made money with or Italian or
Jewish or Irish the rest of the leaders
weren't as progressive as you and View
bloodlines has a great way to gauge if
you can trust someone or not so you all
agreed that only Italians could be
officially inducted into the Mafia how
strict they were with this vary
depending on the family some only
allowed people with a hundred percent
Sicilian bloodlines to join and others
were more relaxed everyone also agreed
to fix the size of each family so that
there could only be so many official
members may men in a family at a time
new main men could only be inducted
after existing mate men passed away this
not only created an aura of extreme
exclusivity and status for the Mafia in
the eyes of aspiring mobsters becoming a
Manman became the ultimate rite of
passage mafiosi dream the bell but it
also served as a great way to make sure
that no family got too ambitious or too
big threatening other families it also
made families be extra careful in the
selection process the holy choose the
very best team members you also
emphasized that being in the Mafia was
to be a lifetime commitment there was no
tiptoeing in this business as you said
the only way out is in a box by your
greatest innovation that would cement
your title as the father of organized
crime was the creation of the Commission
all disputes someone wanted to put a hit
on someone big decisions new rules would
all come down to a votes with each
family having one votes this meant that
everyone was truly equal and to go
against the commission or any one family
was to go to war against all the
families at once if the families played
ball and stay peaceful that we
guaranteed virtually no competition from
the commission members if they didn't
play ball they'll be crushed and what
the Commission formed and the rule set
the American Mafia became custom
designed from the ground up to
efficiently plunder the US and plunder
they did
[Music]
the creation of the Commission in 1931
can be compared to something like the
creation of the internet Lowe's I got on
the Internet flourished and those who
weren't a part of it perish to kind of
like members of the Commission
that's how revolutionary lucky Luciano's
idea was he was a true visionary a Steve
Jobs or Elon Musk of the criminal
underworld and although everyone knew
Luciano was practically the boss of all
bosses he didn't need to feed his ego
and make the same mistake his own bosses
made by formally declaring it the
Commission would meet every five years
and the new structure will launch the
Mafia into a new period of unparalleled
peace and prosperity that will last for
decades to come
prohibition gave this new generation of
mobsters irreplaceable on-the-job
experience of how to best organize
people and resources making them
Millions
and when prohibition came to a sad end
in 1933 they had more than enough booth
leaking money to use a startup capital
for more creative rackets they went to
bookmaking loan-sharking prostitution
narcotics trafficking robberies cargo
hijackings the numbers game and much
more with the united the five family
slowly but surely destroyed their Irish
and Jewish competition as they tightened
their grip on New York they became
experts at corrupting law enforcement
the press judges and anyone and everyone
would power and influence and Lucky
Luciano got a cut of all that action
making him the most powerful mobster in
all of New York but no one is lucky
forever and Luciano's luck would sooner
announce
the rise of the ambitious Luciano also
gave rise to an equally ambitious
prosecutor named Thomas Dewey Dewey was
the Batman to the Joker of Luciano an
incorruptible idealist prosecutor for
the Justice Department hell-bent on
taking down organized crime and he was
tasked with the challenge of prosecuting
a new kind of criminal that the justice
system had never dealt with before the
modern-day racketeer who never did any
of the dirty work himself from the
beginning do we faced an almost hopeless
job clearing out gangsters and
racketeers whose hold upon the city had
been tightening through years of Tammany
rule and after some clever legal
maneuverings and discovery one of
Lucky's rackets a giant brothel Network
codenamed the combine do we rated 80
brothels at the same time and got 68
prostitutes and other workers to testify
in exchange for better deals to testify
that lucky ran the place Dewey's goal
was to paint the prostitutes as poor
desperate victims of the Great
Depression that lucky took advantage of
and Luciano was sentenced to 30 to 50
years in prison ironically lucky getting
thrown into prison was the ultimate test
to see just how robust his concept of
organized crime really was the leader
was stripped from the organization
thrown into prison and yet business went
on as usual
lucky assigned someone to act as the
acting boss and the money kept flowing
in a set nothing changed although lucky
continued to have the final say in
matters and practically ran the prison
life for Luciano was a slow gradual
downhill fall from there once he was our
prison do we got him deported back to
Italy
and from that point on although he tried
lucky never got to see his beloved home
of New York ever again until he died of
a heart attack at age 64 and was allowed
to be buried in Queens New York
[Music]
Luciano was very innovative but here's
the thing if he didn't know Italian he
would have gone nowhere the reason he
was eventually able to get through to
the more traditionalist bosses at the
time was partly because they viewed him
as part of their culture he was full
Sicilian and knew Italian today things
are different people were more open to
outsiders but the fact remains it is a
thousand times easier to influence
someone if you are a part of their
culture their tribe if they view you as
similar to them whether that be a mafia
boss the potential love of your life
business prospects or potential new
employer and a big part of that is
speaking their language this is word
Babel comes in buona sera
why not Sara we wanna say that I did it
guys Babel is a language learning map
that prepares you for situations that
you'll actually encounter in real life
invite size ten to fifteen minute
lessons available on any device you can
choose from 13 different languages
including Italian and it has a 4.5 star
rating from over 600,000 people on both
the Google Play Store and the Apple
Store Babel is unique compared to other
apps because just 21 hours on it is the
equivalent to a whole semester at
college at a fraction of the price and
after going through a few lessons myself
I can definitely see why it's way more
efficient than courses I've taken in
school and a lot of fun or - and for a
limited time Babel is offering you 50%
off the further sweeten the deal you can
sign up right now with the link below
and support the brands that helped make
this channel possible
welcome to the watch the end Club and if
you guys enjoyed this video and you
haven't seen my first video on the Mafia
called the economics of the Mafia people
really enjoy that one so I will link it
down below and on the end of this video
on the end screen a surprising amount
people asked for a video on the yakuza
so I will probably make that in the very
near future just make sure you're
subscribed by clicking that red button
below so you get more free video essays
like this on the most provocative stuff
in the world of business every single
week as always you guys can let me know
what other videos you want to see in the
comments down below if you want to
support this channel financially you can
check out the video sponsor for today
you could follow me on instagram at jake
trend io you guys have been very awesome
I've been Jake I'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
well I might fairway
- always - purpose changes and scars